bonsoir la science est une école
d'émerveillement de vérité et de
citoyenneté
parce que les ces trois éléments
elle a sa place dans l'éducation écoles
d'émerveillement apprendre à l'enfant à
regarder le monde saboter les phénomènes
qu'ils habitent et qui lui pose des
questions
école de vérité parcourir avec lui la
longue histoire d'émergence de cette
vérité dans l' aventure humaine qui a
été celle de la science depuis la nuit
des temps
lui montrer comment cette vérité se
construit par des débats des hypothèses
des conclusions parfois hasardeuses et
finalement à quel point elle est
libératrice et elle permet de compte non
seulement de comprendre le monde mais
d'agir sur lui comme la technique
aujourd'hui si présente nous le révèle
enfin école de citoyenneté
parce que la science de par son
caractère universel est partagé par
toute l'humanité à des degrés inégaux
bien sûr mais quand elle se construit
elle se construit dans un dialogue où la
culture la religion l'origine sociale
n'ont plus d'importance ce qui compte
c'est la recherche commune par les
changes de cette vérité donc ces trois
caractères font que la science comme
école à sa place dans cet immense
entreprise que l'éducation car quelle
éducation
d'abord lé transmission d'une culture de
tout ce qui a été construit avant que
nous mêmes et les enfants nous avons la
charge viento monde
nous sommes comme le disait un penseur
du 12e siècle air de chartres des nains
mais nous sommes des nains montés sur
des épaules de géants et c'est pour
hisser l'enfant sur ses épaules que nous
lui transmettons l'éducation mais
l'éducation est aussi apprendre à
regarder apprendre regarder le présent
non plus le passé instruit par le passé
apprendre à regarder le présent le monde
sous nos yeux si différent de celui de
nos pères nos grands-pères de livres là
monde qui se fait et le regardais n'est
pas toujours aisé d'autant plus que ce
monde est marqué par la science par la
technique par des changements
extrêmement rapide
enfin préparer l'avenir et quelles
tâches plus importantes pour l'école que
de préparer chaque enfant et chaque
adolescent à son avenir quelle
inquiétudes plus grandes que celles des
parents et des éducateurs
devant cet avenir pour faire cela
comment donner sa place à la science
dans l'école c'est la question que s'est
posée il ya 20 ans tout juste
georges charpak il s'est demandé comment
nos enfants de france pouvait pratiquer
la science non pas la prendre d'abord
mais en faire dans l'école et il a fondé
ce mouvement qui s'appelle la main à la
pâte qui s'est répandue dans le monde
entier si bien aujourd'hui que quand je
suis en chine en amérique latine en
australie dans les conférences ont par
le chinois anglais français espagnol
mais on dit toujours la main à la pâte
c'est dire que cette idée de rendre
l'enfant actifs par une pédagogie qui le
met lui même en position de découverte a
eu des échos dans le monde entier
georges charpak était un visionnaire il
avait compris bien avant tout le monde
que la place de la science dans nos
sociétés étaient un enjeu majeur pour
l'éducation
comment assurer cette place bien sûr en
accompagnant les professeurs et la main
à la pâte conduite par l'académie des
sciences depuis 20 ans maintenant et
d'innombrables partenariats avec des
écoles des collèges des chercheurs se
préoccupe de cet accompagnement
les professeurs souvent à l'école
primaire en particulier ont peur
l'enseigné la science ils ont peur de
faire des expériences
elle pourrait rater ils craignent
parfois les questions des enfants de ne
pas savoir répondre il faut les
accompagner
c'est pour les accompagner que nous
avons mis en place un très grand nombre
de ressources et en particulier c'était
très novateur et 10 à 20 ans un site
internet qui reçoit environ trois
millions et demi de requêtes
d'enseignants parents donc il ya un
véritable besoin auquel il faut répondre
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'une classe
ou on fait de la science est bien
mettons là dans la cour de récréation
plantes ont un piquet dans la cour et
regardons au fil d'une journée
ensoleillée
l'ombre du piquet se déplacer pourquoi
se déplacer
et pourquoi sa longueur change-t-elle et
pourquoi demain sera t elle différente
et combien de temps s'est écoulé entre
chacune des positions
autant de questions qui brille dans les
yeux des enfants qui viennent sur leurs
lèvres
autant de questions dont il faut
construire les réponses pour que le soir
quand ils rentreront au dîner familial
il puisse dire à leurs parents
papa maman aujourd'hui j'ai mesuré comme
le grec eratosthène il ya 25 ans 25 y
est le pardon avec l'ombre d'un bâton la
circonférence de la terre ses quarante
mille kilomètres quelle fierté
inoubliable par un enfant de 12 ans que
de pouvoir dire ça la pédagogie active
de cet enseignement de science elle met
en valeur la curiosité l'imagination de
l'enfant
elle met en valeur son discernement
son esprit critique son jugement sa
raison elle met en valeur sa capacité à
manipuler à expérimenter son habileté
manuelle la main guidée par la pensée et
la pensée guidée par la main
elle met en valeur sa capacité de
langage
son usage pertinent du français la
richesse du vocabulaire pour désigner
les objets du monde qui l'entourent
elle met en valeur la capacité d'écrire
comme un grand comme un scientifique
dans son laboratoire comme un ingénieur
dans son bureau d'études
il tiendra un cahier d'expérience et je
peux vous dire qu'un cahier d'expérience
qui va du ce2 au cm2 et riche d'une
somme de découverte que je crois là
encore l'enfant double ira jamais alors
ce propos
il s'adresse aux enfants mais il est
l'objet de la médiation du professeur
donc il nous faut accompagner les
professeurs par tous les outils que la
main à la pâte a mis en place au cours
de ses 20 ans le corps enseignant a
suivi beaucoup ce projet avec étonnement
et pourquoi sommes-nous suivi je crois
que beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes
aujourd'hui qui voit l'évolution du
monde sont perplexes
le monde est devenu extrêmement complexe
il faut le comprendre mais il faut aussi
résonné sur lui ce sont des éléments
indispensables pour situer indispensable
pour trouver un métier quand les jeunes
sortiront de l'école indispensable pour
manipuler internet les outils numériques
avec intelligence indispensable pour
dépasser les opinions toutes faites
jugé en tant que citoyen éclairé
responsables des grandes questions du
monde d'aujourd'hui
le changement climatique la perte de la
biodiversité l'utilisation de l'énergie
et bien d'autres qui appelle un
comportement raisonnée de la part de ces
enfants devenus adultes et citoyens ce
comportement raisonnée il n'est pas
simple car le monde n'est pas simple il
se construit et cette construction à
laquelle l'école doit aider alors bien
sûr devenir un citoyen éclairé
responsable suppose d'autres valeurs
outre celle que la science peut
transmettre les valeurs de solidarité de
justice de miséricorde ne sont pas
celles avec lesquelles la science
travail pour élaborer la vérité
ces valeurs-là elle touche à l'humain à
tout l'humain de façon beaucoup plus
ample mais la science et l'éducation
sciences à l'école peut apporter sa
petite pas en apprenant à l'enfant a
résonné juste à penser droit à tenir
compte des faits et peut-être surtout à
avoir confiance dans sa propre
intelligence et dans l'espoir que nous
pouvons lui communiquer que le monde
n'est pas pour toujours sans possibilité
d'agir sur lui il ya d'autres manières
d'agir que la science et la technique
mais nul ne niera qu'aujourd'hui ces
manières sont devenus essentiels alors
communiquer aux jeunes la confiance en
soi et l'espoir dans le lendemain n'est
ce pas ce qu'ils attendent avant tout de
nous aujourd'hui je remercie